all of this the situation with the
outgoing
president the prospects for the incoming
administration
joe manchin is democratic senator from
west virginia he joins us now
welcome back to special report good to
be with you brett how are you
i'm doing well happy new year i want to
talk to you first about the impeachment
effort
you know the house it seems is going to
vote the day after tomorrow
on impeachment it seems like house
speaker pelosi is going to have the
votes
is there any scenario where you see that
the u.s senate
would try and convict president trump
i don't see any of that because you know
if there will be 48 still 48 democrats
until we see uh warnock and uh senator
ossoff
uh so until that happens you need 67
votes i think my arithmetic that means
we have 19
republicans i don't see that and i think
that house should know that also we've
been trying to
send that message over they know the
votes ontario you would think that they
would do that i think this is
so ill-advised for joe biden to be
coming in
trying to heal the country trying to be
the president of all the people when
we're going to be so divided and
fighting again uh
let's let the judicial system do its job
brett and then
you know we're we're a country the rule
law that's the bedrock of who we are
let that take its place let the
investigations go on let the evidence
come forth and then we'll go forth
from there there's no rush to do this
this impeachment now we can do it later
if they think it's necessary
but is there any credibility to doing an
impeachment trial after the president's
already left office
here's the thing the politics that you
would you know yes i think that
basically
if it comes to that point and there's
enough evidence that we show and we have
proven evidence of what we've seen
already and there's probably more
that we haven't seen and i don't think
that basically you can ever condone the
type of
actions that's happening the
insurrection uh that's happened to our
to our country and to our capital uh but
with that uh that if they're trying to
do it now it's not going to happen he'll
be out of office
no matter what happens because mitch
does not going to take it up mitch is
still the majority leader
until the two new senators are sworn in
so
mitch doesn't have unanimous consent to
bring it up to take it up immediately so
they can pass it
tomorrow the day after send it over and
uh
mitch won't take it up and basically
until the 19th and nothing would start
until after joe biden
is sworn in as president senator there
are some of your colleagues who are
saying that republicans
who voted uh to challenge the electoral
college or voted against that
certification
or other colleagues who talked openly
about
uh stop the steal should somehow be
disciplined some of your colleagues have
even said they should be thrown out
of the senator the house where are you
well the senate
the senators there's only 100 of us
brett you know how the power that the
constitution gives each senator
they were acting within the confines it
was bad i think it was very very very
bad judgment and those
who held their ground i could not
believe it you know after we all
gathered and took us down that secure
place
and we were all there together three
four five hours i spoke to each one of
them that says
please you see what's happened we didn't
know the gravity of what had happened
brett until we went down
into that secured area and we saw the
monitors
we couldn't believe what we were seeing
because we had no idea
it was at that level at all so once we
saw that and then we heard about
the deaths and there might be more uh i
talked to
those people who were objecting and i
said i know you have the right within
the senate to do as you're doing but
look at what you're doing to our country
shouldn't you think about this
we're better than this and i think five
or seven of them
did not they changed their minds and i
was proud to see that happening
but those who went and doubled down
afterwards and
we went over for the pennsylvania boat
vote brett we were in the house chamber
and
pennsylvania uh congregation stood up
and i think
had to be 50 60 70 republican congress
people stood up and still
doubling down and josh hawley stood up
and uh confirmed with the senate so we
went back over to the senate
and it was voted down again by over 90
to but just to be clear you're not
saying that they should be disciplined
for that they were operating within the
confines of
that vote brett they have to live with
their conscience they have to
live with themselves they have to go to
their
constituents i want to move on i talked
to you back november
um and we were forecasting about these
georgia runoffs
it was an uphill battle for democrats
they thought to win both they did
and now technically have control of the
of this the chamber
in the new congress although it's
tenuous here's what you told me about
the filibuster back then i will not be
the 50th democrat
voting to end that uh filibuster or to
basically uh bl
stack the court and then all the other
things you're hearing about brett also
is
defund the police i don't know if any of
the democrats in the caucus that are for
defunding the police
we're not for that whatsoever and when
they talk about basically
medicare for all we can't even pay for
medicare for some
all right senator are you in the same
spot today as you were back then
it's all true brett it's all the same
nothing's changed here's the thing brad
my job right now
being in the position i am always being
in the middle is basically going to do
everything in my power to bring this
country together to heal the country
and to work in a bipartisan fashion
which is the white reason
that we have the senate i'm going to do
the job i've always done i'm going to
continue to try
working with the minority and the
majority and now that we're split
we need to bring this country together
and i think people want us to
i can't so if the pressure's on if the
pressure's on from chuck schumer
to get you to break the filibuster to
change the rules
what are you going to tell him i would
say chuck if you sit down and tried to
work with mitch and mitch would you sit
down with chuck can you all
try to work this out can we find some
compromise to where we can get
60 or 65 of us voting for the same thing
i would like to think we could if it's
that important
and sometimes dc statehood let's say
let's take an issue by issue dc
statehood puerto rico statehood you said
you're examining that
in order for that to happen there would
have to be a filibuster
a change in the rules to get to that
vote right
i i don't you know from the standpoint
you're saying there wouldn't be 60
senators to do that i really don't know
i haven't really researched that
you brought up to me the first time
there's been so much going on i'm happy
to look at all of these issues
but i've said what i've said on the
others i want this senate to work
the senate was intended to work the
founding fathers washington madison
jefferson
this was the intent of the senate work
where the minority has input
i've been in the minority and we've had
very little input and i intend
to work with my minority partners to
have input for them
if the pressure senator was too great uh
from democrats
on that front would you become an
independent
you mean i don't i don't think the
democrats will throw me out do you think
i'm not sure i mean where they're going
to throw i'm a good old west virginia
conservative them
there's not a whole i understand that
brett
but i'm still a proud virginian who
loves my proud west virginia republicans
get along at least we used to i hope
they don't push us apart but
i intend to stay where i'm at i can work
i'm very comfortable
and then we'll just have to see what
happens but i'm the pressure doesn't i
mean
i'm too old to be pressured my goodness
what are they going to do to me
i want a place to put my country i love
i love the process we have i want the
democracy to work
i respect my republican my friends
uh i really worked at the i tried like
the dickens to work with the president
for three years i always want my
president to succeed
and i want joe biden to succeed i'm
gonna do everything i can and i would
like to thank my republican colleagues
feel the same i think the dog agrees
with you if you would for a couple more
questions i have a couple more after the
break if you wouldn't mind sticking
around
covert relief package yeah that was held
up for eight months
no but that was their obstruction
i understand this wait
their obstruction no yours too that was
an obstruction
you held out for eight months that is a
total
game changer a new president
and a vaccine this is has simplicity
it's what we've had in our bills it's
for a shorter period of time
but that's okay now because we have a
new president
both speaker nancy pelosi won on 60
minutes last night and won in december
after a new president uh was elected
we're back live with
west virginia democratic senator joe
manchin there's a lot of back and forth
about why that covert relief
was delayed fair to say that the house
speaker
was waiting until the election
is that for me bro yeah
that's to you oh how's that for me now i
i don't know brett i'm not going to
second guess what you know i i didn't
have
any conversations on that i thought it
was ridiculous that we couldn't come to
an agreement before
but you know on the other hand you know
mitch mcconnell started out 1.1 trillion
back in
i think it was in july maybe june or
july when he put
his heels package out and then he came
back after the august
and went down to 500. so i guess in
batman
and just they thought everyone was
dealing in bad faith they hunkered down
in their corners which they do an awful
lot and nothing got accomplished
until we got the bipartisan bicameral
group together
to find out what the emergency and the
absolute the people that would lose
everything
you know we just we just need to start
working in a new era of bipartisanship
it's really what it's all about and with
comments senator schumer
senator says he wants to move forward
with the 2 000 direct payment
checks do you have problem with that
i'm going to tell you i will do whatever
it takes to help those people in need
whatever it takes to keep this economy
but i wanted to be targeted brett
i wanted to be targeted to make sure it
gets to the people
that need the help that's all i've said
uh and i'll do whatever it takes
to help our economy and help those
people in need but let's make sure it's
targeted
let's make sure it's getting to the
right place have you spoken to
president-elect biden
yes i have um and his
feelings about about this i don't want
to get into the private conversation
you've had but
there's obviously i talked to you about
pressure uh from chuck schumer on you
uh there's obviously going to be
pressure on
then after january 20th president biden
from the progressive side of your party
how do you think he deals with that
specifically let me
let me tell you we talked about that i
will tell you that we talked about that
and i said
mr president i said you know i have i'm
i have some pretty uh pretty strong
beliefs
and and i really want the place to work
i think you have the greatest
opportunity
the greatest opportunity with the
knowledge you have of how this senate
and how congress is supposed to work
because you've been in it and have more
experience than anyone since lyndon
may's johnson said in that
position that you have right now coming
into so with that use it use the
knowledge you have bring us all back
together
and he says joe i'll never ask you to
vote for something or i'll never ask you
to go against your convictions i says i
know that mr president-elect i know that
joe biden
and i appreciate that very much because
i am who i
am i said we're all a product of our
environment you are who you are
but how you was raised where you're
raised and who raised you and i was very
fortunate to have wonderful people
but i think you know we talked about our
upbringing you come from scranton i come
from
little farmington west virginia most
beautiful little town but
a little coal mining town a little
hard-working people but he gets it he
understands it he won't put that
pressure that's the worst thing
you can do is put pressure you can
basically bring the fact
i missed something tell me change yeah
quickly
how do you think confirmations will
happen quickly
i sure hope it does but you know this
impeachment doesn't help anything
that's the thing i'm talking about makes
no sense whatsoever that we would push
this impeachment
thinking we're going to do a little bit
of this a little bit of that it doesn't
work that way
let the judicial system do its job if
you still think it's needed for
impeachment
do it later but the bottom line joe
biden should want us to put
a government together confirm
immediately we need to get secretary of
defense
we need to get people in place tony
yellen we get
our intelligence we need to protect our
country and get a functioning government
as quickly as possible and get people
vaccinated
immediately warp speed i said i
appreciate the president
bringing a vaccine on uh quicker than
than what we thought could have been
done it's our job now to get it in
people's arms
and protect the citizens of the united
states
do you feel safe does your staff feel
safe
in the u.s capitol
uh i i would hope i do i do i think that
this is a wake-up call
i really think it's a wake-up call i
never felt threatened at all
brett i really didn't but it maybe been
for like i didn't know exactly the
the uh what was going on outside the the
immenseness
of this insurrection but with that being
said yeah i still feel safe
and i think there's a lot of people that
care about our safety there's a lot of
good people out there
and my goodness i don't i don't have an
enemy on either political side i really
don't
my republicans and my friends my
democrat my friend we might disagree
it's not a reason to to to invoke bodily
harm
and what we saw don't you think we have
to have a dialogue to bring people
together
how do we get this far apart how do we
get this
absolutely far apart that it came down
to insurgents that we've seen
insurrection how did we believe that
they think the government is against
them
we better start talking to people not
double down and make it worse
and that's what will happen if we
continue down this road
and i think joe biden i would hope that
he would speak up and say listen
let's work let's put this government
together we'll take care of that later
well senator we appreciate your time
we'd love to continue that conversation
here on special report
well we'll see but at any time i'm happy
to come back thank you
thank you for what you do and i
appreciate it very much